Krylov 양자 대각화, 줄여서 KQD는 행렬 고유값
문제를 Krylov 방법에 따라 양자 컴퓨터에서 준비된 부분 공간으로 투영해서 푸는 방법이에요. 이건
고전 선형대수에서 나온 강력한 접근법이에요. 이 영상에서는 Krylov 방법이 어디에 유용한지,
그리고 양자 컴퓨터에서 언제 어떻게 구현하는지 살펴볼 거예요.
그러면 Krylov 방법이 뭘까요? 과학이나 비즈니스 문제와 관련된 n행 n열짜리 행렬 H가 있다고 해봐요.
우리는 가장 낮은 고유값 e0와 그에 대응하는 고유벡터 사이즈0에 관심이 있어요. 초기
벡터 v를 정의해봐요. 이건 h의 구조에서 착안하거나 완전히 무작위로 선택할 수 있어요. 차수 r의 Krylov 부분 공간,
즉 k r은 이 초기 벡터에 h를 작용시켜서
r minus 1번 반복하고, 각 h 작용의 결과를 기저 벡터 집합에 추가해서 만들어요.
즉, kr은 벡터 v로 생성되는 공간이에요.
hv, h 제곱, 이런 식으로 계속돼요. 이 벡터들은 일반적으로 직교하지 않아요.
고전적으로는 Graham-Schmidt 절차와 매우 유사한 직교화 과정을 수행하는 경우가 많아요. 초기
벡터 V를 정규화해서 그 결과를 V0이라고 불러요. 그 다음 벡터 HV의 경우, V0 위로의
투영을 빼서 두 벡터를 직교하게 만들어요. 그런 다음 결과를 정규화해요. 이 과정을 계속해서,
H를 다시 작용시키고 결과를 이전에 추가된 모든 벡터에 직교하게 만들면서 R개를 쌓아가요.
R차원 Krylov 부분 공간을 생성하는 데 필요한 직교 정규화된 벡터들이죠.
이 부분 공간을 얻으면, 행렬을 거기에 투영하고 더 작은 투영 행렬을 대각화해요. 여러
세부 사항과 확장이 있지만, 이게 가장 간단한 수준의 Krylov 방법이에요.
어떻게 작동하는지 더 잘 이해하기 위해 간단한 예를 살펴봐요. H가 이 행렬이고 V가 이
벡터로 선택되면, 먼저 V를 정규화해요. Krylov 부분 공간에서 두 번째 벡터를 생성하려면, 초기 벡터에
H를 한 번 작용시키고 그 결과를 V0에 직교하게 만들어요.
간단한 대수 계산을 하면 V1이 이렇게 나와요.
이런 작은 행렬에는 유용하지 않고, 보통 Krylov 차원이 2에서 멈추지도 않아요. 하지만 만약
H를 새로운 Krylov 공간 K2로 투영하려면, 각 열이 Krylov 벡터인 행렬 V와
각 행이 Krylov 벡터인 켤레 전치 행렬을 사용해요. 그러면
이런 행렬을 얻게 돼요.
이 행렬은 기술적으로 원래 행렬보다 차원이 낮아요. 당연히 이 규모에서는 이런 축소가 유용하지 않아요.
이 방법은 수천 또는 수백만 행과 열을 가진 행렬을
소수로 줄이기 위한 거예요. 그러면 Krylov 방법이 왜 유용할까요? 이 간단한 처방,
즉 연산자 작용이 행렬 연산자의 가장 낮은 값 상태나 바닥 상태에 접근하는
가장 효율적인 방법인 경우가 많다는 게 밝혀졌어요. 좀 더 명확하게 해봐요. 전체 증명은 수반 텍스트에 맡길게요. 우리가
풀려는 문제는 벡터 x에 h가 작용하면 어떤 상수 곱하기 벡터 x가 되는 형태예요. 먼저
고유벡터 x0를 추측해봐요. 이건 단순히 근사해예요. 오차가 있는데 이를 e0라고 불러요. 이제 우리는
이 추측을 갱신하고 싶은데, 이를 x1이라고 부를게요. 이게 우리의 근사를 개선하길 기대해요. 이걸
원래의 x0에 아직 결정되지 않은 보정 p0를 더한 것으로 표현할 수 있어요.
이 과정을 더 많은 보정 벡터 pi를 추가하면서 반복적으로 계속할 수 있어요.
당연히 오차가 줄어들길 원하지만, 상태만 신경 쓰는 게 아니에요. 우리는 또한
그 상태에 h가 작용하는 것도 신경 써요. 그래서 실제로 최소화하려는 양은 이 오차의 h 노름,
즉 이 오차에 h가 작용한 것의 노름이에요.
이제 이게 p0를 포함하는 식임을 알 수 있고, p가 이 오차의 h 노름을
가장 효율적으로 최소화하는 선택이 무엇인지 물어볼 수 있어요. 어떤 공간에서 보정을 선택해야 할까요? 특정
조건, 예를 들어 h가 대칭이고 양의 정부호인 경우, kr 내에서 첫 번째 r개의 보정을 선택하는 것이
최적임이 밝혀져 있어요. 더 쉽게 말하면, 우리는 Hamiltonian을 투영할
좋은 부분 공간을 준비하는 방법이 필요해요. 그리고 많은 경우, Krylov 부분 공간이 초기 추측에 대한
가장 효율적인 보정들이 생성하는 공간이에요.
실제 증명은 이 영상에 수반된 텍스트를 참고해요.
지금까지 설명한 모든 것은 고전적으로도 할 수 있어요. 그렇다면 양자 컴퓨터는 언제 어떻게 사용할까요?
매우 큰 행렬의 경우, Krylov 방법은 긴 계산 시간과 많은 메모리를 필요로 할 수 있어요. V에
H를 행렬 연산하는 데 걸리는 시간은 최악의 경우 N 제곱에 비례해요.
그리고 이건 부분 공간에서 원하는 모든 벡터에 대해 수행돼요. 부분 공간 차원 R은 보통 N의
큰 비율이 아니고 종종 log N처럼 증가해요. 그래서 모든 벡터를 생성하는 건
N 제곱 log N 정도예요.
직교화 같은 다른 단계들도 있지만, 이게 기억해야 할 지배적인 스케일링이에요.
양자 컴퓨팅은 문제의 어떤 속성이 시간과 자원 스케일링을 결정하는지
바꿀 수 있어요. 전반적으로 행렬 크기 n에 의존하는 대신, 측정 횟수(shots)나
Hamiltonian을 구성하는 비가환 Pauli 항의 수 같은 것들이 보여요.
이게 어떻게 작동하는지 살펴봐요.
양자 상태를 시간 진화시키는 연산자가 iH를 h bar로 나눈 것의 지수 함수라는 걸 기억해요. 그리고
양자 컴퓨팅, 특히 표기법에서 h bar를 생략하는 게 매우 일반적이에요.
연산자의 지수 함수를 이해하고 실현하는 한 가지 방법은 Fourier
급수 전개를 보는 거예요. 이 연산이 초기 벡터 V에 작용하면 항들의 합이 나온다는 걸 알아두세요.